Hi, I'm Lenny Henry, and we're playing
quickfire questions.
What name would I give to my weapon?
Erm...
Michu and Bony,  who are the two most
famous players to play for Swansea City.
The only name is coming to
my mind is Vivian.
I don't know...
I don’t think I would call it that.
Jeff the Bat
Kardashians have named one of their dogs Sushi.
And I love sushi.
And I thought it was a really cool
name for a dog.
So... Sushi?
Ooh, I think we did give it a name.
I think they're referring to my Staff of Knowledge, which is beautiful and...
Erm... I can’t remember what it’s bloody called!
We called it The Answer.
I don't think I would be at liberty
to make that decision without conferring
with my celestial twin
and partner in crime, Syndril.
Syndril has... a shared magic
with Zacaré,
so I have to confer with her.
If I could
pick a creature to represent my clan,
I would pick koalas.
So I've been told because of my bald head
and my laid back nature,
I sometimes resemble a turtle.
So I would go with a turtle coming
out of the shell.
Whippet!
I would make it Penguin Clan.
Penguins.
Which doesn't sound as formidable as Dog,
Serpent and Raven.
Just waddling about on the Continent.
Just... Just being adorable.
I love penguins.
My heart’s kinda set on Dog Clan.
I have to be have to be loyal to the guys, y’know?
Which song snaps me out of beast mode?
A Case of You by Joni Mitchell.
I’d just get really sad.
We built this city.
We built this city in Xin’trea.
We built this city!
Wannabe by the Spice Girls.
Because at the first, like the opening,
I thought I would really like
that would snap you out, for sure.
Spice Girls.
I wanna make you holler, holler!
That's your old school
Scrap that. Kendrick Lamar's...
We gon' be alright
We gon' be alright.
Be humble. Sit down.
Be humble.
I don't think we should say that.
Sit down.
Yeah, sorry.
I think I would feel pretty...
Pretty safe
with Zacaré.
Scían, played by Michelle Yeoh.
Fierce.
Meldof is a force to be reckoned with.
I would like Meldof. just because
I think we'd have a right f**cking laugh.
Michelle Yeoh.
I would like to defend me in all battles.
The Lark can kill 15 blokes
while she's sipping a pint
and doing needlework at the same time.
You don't mess with The Lark.
- We are not dying here.
If I could travel anywhere
with the powers of a monolith,
I would most likely
just consistently be my bed.
Oh, there's so many places...
Dudley!
Dudley in the West Midlands,
near Dudley Zoo. We've got a canal.
Come on, get a monolith
up there in the town center.
Somewhere under the ocean.
And there's a breathing problem.
I think I'd probably travel to Iceland,
where some of our beautiful show was shot.
I'd probably go back and look at the
dinosaurs, see what's going on.
If I got to trade weapons
with another member of The Seven,
it would be a tie between...
Soulreaver and Brother Death’s cleavers.
Just to wind up Brother Death, really.
They just look so,
like, so terrifying and impressive.
So, yeah,
I think cleaver in each hand be great.
I'm going to go with Meldof and Gwen
I just think
it's the coolest hammer in the world,
but obviously not as good as the cleavers.
But I have to choose one.
So, yeah.
Sofia Brown
has these gorgeous little daggers
and you'll see the way she moves them...
It’s effortless.
And I think there's something quite free
about that. I think would be quite cool.
Now, you can’t tell her this, right?
But I probably would get the two blades.
I think I want that big, stabby axe thing
that Fjall’s got
because that would be a very good
thing for cutting pies into quarters.
Brother Death’s cleavers.
‘Cause I don’t have a lot of finesse.
- I'm sorry. I'm sorry!